We know what you whisper they had
lost their protector now is our time
you saw an underwater Empire
yes but these people are
dangerous there's a new world
are you an ally or an enemy
he's coming for the surface world
only the most broken people can be great leaders
introducing namor was really an opportunity to
introduce another Sovereign ruler of a group
of people he shows up representing talocon he's
coming for the surface World in Marvel publishing
namor was one of the first superheroes frankly
they called him the feather serpent God Namor
loves his people and he's gonna protect them
because to be a ruler you have to serve the
people that's a deep meaning for me is part of
my personal Heritage as a Mexican as inhabitant
of mesoamerica finally I could find a more
powerful representation of my culture with
dignity and respect I cannot wait for everyone
to see talukan I'm excited about how we're gonna
see the world come alive both nations want
the same thing which is to to preserve and
to protect their people but they're willing
to go about it different ways I need to work
Namor is very much concern with
what he needs and what he wants
this delicate dance between the two of
them I get chills just thinking about it
my enemies call me no more
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Marvel
dropped a couple new black panther wakanda
forever trailers and clips so we'll break it
all down there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
obviously there's a bunch of big stuff coming up
in Marvel phase five and this is sort of like the
last big thing in Marvel phase four setting it
all up if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos I believe I'm
allowed to post my non-spoilery review on Tuesday
so that should be up by Tuesday morning my full
post credit scene video Easter eggs breakdown
to the entire movie will post later next week
after it actually comes out in theaters so be
sure to go see it as soon as possible because
of what they're doing with the ironheart RiRi
Williams character I know there's a lot of
questions about the legacy of Iron Man Easter
eggs during the movie and how they're going to
deal with him going forward into Marvel Phase
5 and Marvel phase six because we have Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty Avengers 6 Secret Wars a lot of
Kang's technology iterates on things that Iron
Man did one of the big differences between Kang
and the other people that sort of iterate on Iron
Man's ideas and his technology to try and make
it better is that Kang has just had millions of
years because of the way that he plays with time
travel we'll start to see that during Ant-Man 3
Quantumania with the kang the Conqueror version
of his character which is sort of like him in
his prime you also have to remember that Kang
was born many many thousands of years in the
future and the he who remains immortus version
of Kang that we saw during the Loki series was
him at the end of all time like the end of his
timeline but the end of all time in general like
the heat death of the universe billions of years
in the future so he'd had billions of years to
make Iron Man's technology even better it's sort
of that idea that all technology is built on
what came before like okay that guy over there
built these things I think I could do a slightly
better version using slightly different materials
and that's where you get to all the vibranium and
all of shuri's technology and her work in wakanda
because she's one of the few characters in the MCU
that just doesn't immediately look at everything
that Iron Man is doing and try to copy on it this
is one of the things they try to get across in the
first Black Panther movie in Avengers Infinity war
and also what's going on in Black Panther wakanda
forever with name orbs people in talocan because
those two cultures like talocan and wakanda are
meant to be 2 two different nations that were
completely isolated from the rest of the world
for most of their evolution the only difference
in present day is that t'challa was trying to
open their borders more and more at the end of
the first Black Panther movie and allow more
cultural influences into the country which is
where you get to all the Starbucks wakanda jokes
Starbucks the idea in Black Panther Wakanda
forever is that it's just starting to happen
to namor's people in talocan like they're way more
isolationist the way that the wakandas used to be
before t'challa came along so obviously during the
movie you have this very literal connection Easter
eggs through River Williams ironheart character
and they did have a much deeper Connection in the
comics but because in the present day the MCU the
way they're treating the Iron Man character in The
616 Universe he's completely gone like we haven't
seen any kind of AI technology where he left his
Consciousness around in the comics he pulled the
very Jarvis twist with his Consciousness where he
was still kind of around any of it seemed like
he died they preserved his body and then Marvel
Comics went through a bunch of big changes and
they just sort of redid the Iron Man comics with
the new number one in the MCU their big plan for
the Iron Man character long term is basically to
bring him back during Avengers six Secret Wars
using a Multiverse kind of twist so they don't
have to walk back the sacrifice of the 616 Iron
Man at the end of Avengers end game like they
still want to have that very powerful moment he
sacrificed himself to say this entire universe
him coming back would kind of walk back that
sacrifice so when Robert Downey Jr comes back as
a version of Iron Man or even as another character
the sorcerer's Supreme version of Tony Stark it'll
be closer to like a Multiverse kind of twist they
kind of started to do that during Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness they were gonna do a version
of Tony Stark from the Multiverse with another
actor but because they got John Krasinski to come
back as Mr Fantastic the Fantastic Four they got
Anson Mount to come back as Black Bolt and they
got Patrick Stewart to come back as a version of
Professor X from the X-Men animated series it was
more of an Easter egg for the Animated Series than
it was for the fox films but they said that he was
meant to be like in amalgam version of all those
different versions of Professor X rolled into one
and because they had wanted to get Tom Cruise for
Iron Man but he was too unavailable busy filming
the mission impossible sequels they just opted
to not do the character entirely like you know
we'll kind of reference him in the background
but we're not going to do him on screen for a
while so because Iron Man isn't around anymore
in the 616 Universe you have riril Williams
at MIT where Iron Man went he set up all those
scholarships he funded all the those programs
it sounds like she benefited from that like she
got in on a scholarship because she's from this
very underprivileged family Iron Man had been one
of her Heroes growing up so she took a lot of his
ideas and iterated on those which is why a lot of
her scenes seem similar to scenes from the first
Iron Man movie because her character goes to a lot
of the same beats like building her first dumpster
dive version of her armor her Mark won her cave
scene so to speak but where it diverges from comic
book ironheart and Iron Man stuff is where you get
all the shuri and the wakanda stuff like they
come to protect her take her to wakanda and she
builds her Mark II using all of shuri's technology
which are completely different ideas even though a
lot of the results seem very similar we'll still
see a lot of Easter eggs and references to Iron
Man in the Iron Hard series when we get to that
because black panther wakanda forever is meant
to directly set that up like this is the ironheart
series is a direct sequel to wakanda forever but
I think what they're trying to do with her plot
in wakanda forever and all the stuff with shuri
and her technology in wakanda is separate the
Ironheart character from Iron Man so that she
doesn't feel like ironheart Jr going forward in
the MCU like she's not meant to be a version of
iron ladder or anything like that even though I'm
sure there'll be a lot of questions about that
going forward like is she like a young version of
Kang pretending to be Iron lad in the MCU because
that would be a crazy twist I don't think that's
the case with this version of RiRi Williams but we
might see a version of that in the future where we
see a young version of Kang just pretending to be
Iron lad like he does in the comics speaking of
Kang I'm also kind of hoping that they use Rama
Tut as a character inside the new Fantastic Four
movie that would actually be pretty crazy because
Doctor Doom isn't supposed to be the villain of
the next Fantastic Four movie I've already done a
couple Doctor Doom videos so I'll link those in
the description below I'll talk more about him
after black panther what kind of forever comes out
because there is a little bit of Doctor Doom stuff
going on in the background in the movie but not
as much as people think and he's not like a huge
character or anything like that in the movie we
won't actually see him on screen for a while but
later on we'll find out how he was involved in a
lot of the things that were happening right now
like it was Doom all along kind of energy Agatha
all along but with Dr Doom the other big question
I know people have is what is Namor's role in the
MCU going forward because obviously they want to
play him like more of an anti-hero he's not meant
to be a true villain in this movie even though
he is a huge in the comics so the whole idea is
you have to remember is that talocan even though
its underwater has basically all the same stuff
that wakanda does they have access to all this
underwater vibranium they have all this advanced
technology and one of their big advantages is
because their bodies evolve to live at that death
underwater they're way more resilient way faster
way stronger so they're a little bit more like the
asgardians like this low-level super soldier Army
that they can use in battles even above water in
a water-based battle their advantage multiplies by
like 10 fold there is a big water battle during
wakanda forever so obviously we'll be talking
about that the other difference with Namor is that
he's a full-blown mutant whereas the rest of his
people are not that's how he can fly he also has
most of the same powers that Captain America has
just a little bit better like he's a little bit
more resilient a little bit faster A Little Bit
Stronger Than Captain America and he's covered
head to toe in vibranium whereas Captain America
only had the shield that was vibranium so heading
into something like Avengers 5 Kang Diamond SD
you could use nameor it's just a really badass
fighter during the movie but during Avengers 6
Secret Wars when you have all the rest of the
Multiverse combined into that one single battle
World scenario he can become ruler of all of
Earth's oceans and become way more powerful it
just depends on how closely their version of
Secret Wars is going to be to the comic book
versions of Secret Wars and I think it's going to
be an amalgam of the 80s version of Secret Wars
and the more recent version of Secret Wars with
the obvious difference that instead of Doctor
Doom being behind everything like God Emperor
Doom it'll be king behind everything because
we're going straight from Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty
two secret Wars implant this is going to be a big
Cliffhanger like there was during Avengers
Infinity War heading into Avengers end game
and the way Kevin feige is talking to to invoke
more X-Men mutants stuff by the time we get to
that point it sounds like Kevin feige wants to
have already introduced most of if not all the
new major X-Men characters he didn't say that
they would release the next X-Men movie before
Secret Wars but he did imply that we wouldn't be
waiting that long but before seeing a bunch of
X-Men characters if he spotted any other Easter
eggs in the trailer footage that I didn't talk
about in the video just write down below in
the comments and like I said my non-spoilery
review will post Tuesday morning I've got a
bunch of other bonus videos planned for next
week so be sure to post all your requests in the
comments below if you have any questions about
the characters or what's happening next everyone
click here for my Ant-Man 3 Quantumania trailer
video with a whole bunch of Kang and click
here for my new house of the dragon season
2 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!